ce qui est extravagant dans la situation
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on avait une
politique qui marchait et que nos
dirigeants incapables et corrompus et je
maintiens ont détruit le cadre qui
permettait aux agriculteurs de vivre
je suis très bref qu'est ce que vous
attendez à des sols monsieur pécresse
concrètement concrètement jeter l'un des
seuls à dire sous nicolas sarkozy
quand françois fillon premier ministre
détruisaient les quotas laitiers que ça
allait être une catastrophe industrielle
agricole
on m'a dit non la suppression des quotas
laitiers tout va aller bien
eh bien on a vu le résultat et quand
j'ai demandé au président hollande de
revoir cette décision dramatique de
l'europe
il a dit je peux rien faire quand on a
supprimé les prix garantis du lait
supprimer les prix garantis du lait et
supprimer le système des quotas ont
condamné à mort des milliers d'éleveurs
on le savait il le savait mais ils n'ont
pas fait parce qu'ils obéissent à
bruxelles est ce que vous êtes en plein
pouvoir en france que vous êtes en train
de nous dire que ou le souverainiste
vous êtes pour le retour à une politique
agricole commune européenne
je suis et wendel à pâques je l'est
toujours après d'avant mais la pac
non j'ai toujours défendu l'idée d'une
europe organisé qui respecte les peuples
qui protège les nations c'est à dire la
première europe
une fois qu'on a construit la pac il y
avait quoi il y avait une préférence
communautaire c'est-à-dire un
protectionnisme communautaire il y avait
un prix garanti
il y avait des organisations de marché
et ensuite les gouvernements français
ont démissionné face à leurs partenaires
et ont cédé c'est à dire qu'on a détruit
les sens de la politique agricole
commune et on a abouti au pire des ce1
pire des solutions qui est un système
dérégulé où on n'a même pas la
protection que les éleveurs canadiens ou
américains ont le droit d'avoir il